michel audiard si un personnage insolite
alors dans cet ouvrage c'est vous
d'abord vous en tant qu'auteur parce que
il semble que il semble je sais pas non
pas vous abandonner le cinéma en tout
cas que vous entriez tout à fait en
littérature vous devenez véritablement
un écrivain et se trouvera je le prouve
le confirme et ce qui est curieux c'est
de trouver dans cet ouvrage des phrases
tout à fait mais chante contre le contre
de cinéma positif
voilà vingt ans que je m'emmerde à
écrire des trucs pour gagner des sous
vous semblez dans cet ouvrage rejeté le
cinéma et puis embrasser la littérature
arabe et jean mas a été raturée du rvaj
et serge et c'est en tout cas
mais vous vous parliez tout à l'heure
des des gens ordinaires dont il est
question dans les livres de ce soir et
-7 sega ce sont des petites jambes parce
que il ya quotidien du jeu m'intéresse
véritablement facétieux j'ai en tout cas
envie de mettre dans les livres moi par
exemple je me promène beaucoup c'est
peut-être une des formations de ces
nations c'est rien mais je suis dur
variante fasciné par des gens qu'on voit
dans des squares assis sur des bancs qui
regardent leurs chaussures pendant des
heures comme ça bon ben moi ces gens là
je sais pas si ça vous arrive de moins
je m'assois souvent un goûter 2 et
j'essaie de leur parler bon des fois et
s'ils ne répondent pas je comprends que
les emmerder norvège consiste pas mais
si ils nous racontent leur vie moins
qu'un titre qui reste comme ça france
près des heures il a des problèmes dans
la tête
baradar je fais comme ça vient je sais
mais ça marche
l'uimm l'âge de huit arrivées de
m'asseoir sur des bons mets de
m'endormir
après le déjeuner sacoche alors c'est
comme j'étais ces gens qui qui couchent
sur des des bouches de métro sur des
bancs c'est tout même des gens qui les
tags des bricoles ça vous comprenez
c'est pas les laits les alcooliques ou
les droits y est ils sont pas né
alcoolique qui leur est arrivé des
événements dans la vie or moi fais
événement là c'est ce que je j'essaie de
mettre dans un
il ya quelqu'un qui arrive des bricoles
c'est à michel audiard aussi parce que
celui qui parle c'est bien mais
chaudière jeu pour tromper je cache pas
mon lâché par seconde
or ces plumages cet ouvrage sa
surprendre beaucoup de gens peut-être
qu'ils vous êtes un personnage plutôt
marrant plutôt léger moi je les prie
pour un cri de désespoir et même pour un
cri de haine mais parce qu'il m'est
arrivé le sérieux de l'histoire il a
fallu que je vive longtemps parmi les
chiens pour apprendre à mordre
heureusement ça y est oui parce qu'il
est arrivé dans ma vie un événement
particulier qui a bouleversé pas mal de
choses le bonheur notamment et y compris
les croyances m'a par exemple pendant
jusqu'à chez franck et l'ag du clan
d'oujda ils en mangent et enfants de
coeur comme beaucoup de gens et tout ça
et j'avais le croyant je suis deux fois
le charbonnier je croyais aux obeaux
nuages dans le verger l'outil jésus à la
crèche ou même aux rois mages à la
l'amiral ans enfin tout de la quincaille
et puis d'un seul coup paf moi j'ai vu
près rien du tout parce que j'ai été
lâché et vous croyez à l'écriture en
tout cas maintenant bien entendu les
l'écriture est peut-être le moyen de
dire tout ça sinon le seul aussi là
pendant 30 ans j'ai fait parler les
autres et tout le monde à prendre la
parole un moment donné est ce que c'est
plus difficile de décrire un roman
maintenant j'ai voulu accabler
qu'environnement parce que d'abord c'est
un nouvel exercice pour moi et pour
lequel je suis probablement pas doué
parfait quand j'ai le temps que je
venais à écrire le mal que ça me donne
génie 2 en écrire un livre avec que
j'aurais même peut-être à mon avis dû
réécrire parce qu'un livre est
perfectible à l'infini je crois que j'ai
jamais fini un livre qui semble bon
c'est un livre c'est le gars est un
livre sur les morts que vous avez aimé
que vous aimez ce les morts que vous
comptez sur les morts que vous continuez
de visiter dans les cimetières de
banlieue où ils sont enterrés là ça oui
et bien entendu parce que le le
cimetière est un lieu de
de méditation jour les morts bien
entendu mais sur un tas de choses on est
bien dans un cimetière on les greniers
camilia mirettes et puis on y voit aussi
l'oubli trasim diarra c'est une chose
effarante
non non non non il ne frappe à chaque
fois c'est par exemple ces oublis des
gens regardent et morlaix dans les
cimetières à la toussaint dans les
antennes belles fleurs séchées
c'est tout allez-y trois mois c'est vrai
tout ça est pourri tout c'est fini les
gens y vont une fois par an tradition et
tout cet affreux on oublie tout vous
vous allez sur la gamme ya les cas
exceptionnels
le j'avais lu un article de montherlant
que sur la mort et sur les morts sur le
culte des mains et j'ai eu la curiosité
d'aller montherlant qui n'est pas loin
de chez moi dans l'oise où la tombe de
famille disloquée effondré lamentable le
same as et je veux dire ce qui n'allait
qui ne va pas mais un débat qui ne
correspondaient pas oui je les allemands
l'annoncé de saison jo d'importantes
c'est sérieux c'est sérieux voilà c'est
nantes et de la chaussure finalement de
la mort de mireille chessa
on est là par exemple joyal des
personnes en particulier
oui on est six à parler on est bien
assise fait journée bien dans 10 15 ans
vont maintenant il en restera là on se
dira plus tard que ce brave machin quand
on a en effet l'émission de pivot à 50 7
en août et l'autobus
vous comprenez pourquoi j'ai déclenché
au caire coco des questions gênantes
mais faute s'est posé ces questions là
on remarque bien moelleux dernière fois
que je faisais dans un cimetière
j'ai vu une dame assez joli les [ __ ]
équipements je suis retournée et je me
plais il ya un petit enfant est lui
apprenait à lire et sa femme ellie me
fahmi y tue ses amis c'était
nous en effet une nouvelle crise qu'il
faut rien faire
irène virage et j'ai bien connu mirettes
chez comme les piles et je parle en fait
j'ai aucune imagination
ouais c'est sûr sans fil j'ai fait
peut-être quatre scénarii mon avis ça
prouve bien que je ne brille pas par
imagination
je veux parler de choses que j'ai vues
de gens que j'ai connus principalement
des gens d'ailleurs parce que je suis
pas un écrivain peut-être seydoux et
pour conseils pour pouvoir 12 pages
d'écrire une tasse de thé je sais pas
faire ça moi pida par les objets
m'intéresse pas tellement c'est des gens
qui m'intéresse alors évidemment
mirettes miradji j'ai connu un temps des
années fille qui on allait danser
ailleurs on sortait ensemble et tous un
jour la libération y tenons printemps de
sable on est quand on a 20 ans ça vous
frappe
qu est ce qu avait fait mirettes à
ecouché a idéalement bons jeunes proches
qui touche je vois pas tout même
l'extravagance qui avait sinon ce métier
là on fait du racisme
on va nager a vieilli ce sont des
événements qui montrent un rib le mans
choquer ou directement été violée
ensuite laissé la place à craig devrait
trancher mais c'étaient des époques
demain sacre alors on sortait d'une
longue époque de massacre on était
retombé dans une autre époque de
massacre quand tu sais que les gars de
ma génération ont pas une jeunesse
marrante
on fait peut-être les rigolos a rappelé
les boulots sont descendus aussi
terriblement appelé barba on a eu du
déchet le titre s'annonce alors on
sortait d
délisia on ne tombait sur d'autres béret
basque arrivant brachard patatrac m'a
fait à recommencer ça je trouvais le
temps un peu longuet vous on pourra
jouer avec eux note aussi et puis avec
eux note mes colocs talent est toujours
là mais finalement il y a alors
personnage sur lequel il ya très peu de
lignes et c'est très émouvant quand on
quand on lui a fait c'est un jeune homme
qui meurt sur l'autoroute du sud dans
une voiture jaune contre l'arche d'un
pont oui d'ailleurs j'ai pas les gaz et
j'agis mon pays et c'est la seule raison
pour laquelle j'ai écrit ce livre dans
le rail c'est un apport en manège parce
qu'il fallait bien habillé ce récit
sinon c'est insupportable à toi pour moi
d'écrire et pour le lecteur probablement
aussi donc tout le reste n'est qu'un
habillage la raison fondamentale de
vivre les pailles oui mais là quand vous
parlez de ce mort qui est votre votre
enfant vous dites celui ci il est
indissoluble de ma vie pas les autres et
bien entendu rien de changé je veux
quand je dis glace sur la voiture
j'étais l'homme cedh est bien évident
avec la mort d'un grand pas les bonnes
choses ont tous guéri
est-ce qu'on peut s'acquérir par
l'écriture par un livre on croit qu'on
exorcisme je prends heureux et vous
remarqué que sorte de revivant ce que
vous appelez selon l'art vivant ce de
ses disparus ne va pas sans quelques
insomnies
parce qu un insomniaque celui qui
raconte tout ça mais bien sûr parce que
il ya une époque de la vie tandis est
passé certaines choses et il est certain
qu'on dort moins bien afin qu'ils
avaient raison et tout alors on met tout
ça dans un livre parce qu'on
al'impression effectivement que ça va
pour masseube purgé que ça va un mois
peut on a écrit le livre puis on en est
quand même pas en aidant même si on en
doute cette balade nocturne dans paris
donc qui durent unis un jour puis
finalement toutes les autres mais parce
qu'elle y aura effectivement
probablement beaucoup apprendre mais
c'est une sorte de pas référence à ces
lignes que vous aimez beaucoup un voyage
au bout de la nuit willaya quelques
critiques qui ont pendant céline prouve
je parle toujours
oui d'ailleurs je vais vers le mal par
nos pages hier et n'a jamais mais à la
vérité je suis je trouve que c'est
toujours bon de parler de céline en tout
état de cause quand on en parle à mon
propos c'est le comble du bonheur je ne
gâcherai pas mais plus de mire c'est un
personnage vivant ils perdent une femme
à ses truculentes qui vend des objets un
peu spéciaux oui ça vous l'avez inventé
ça c'est le romancier ou c'est non à un
allons donc le devenir non non c'est un
jeu dead l'arbre nocturne comme on a
beaucoup je peux être une femme c'est
pas des questions sentimentales jeunes
lors de sa alors on a tous peut-être une
plus à dormir ou encore tanger qui ont
atterri vers 16 heures quand on a un
petit peu traîné ça fait du bien s'il
fait chaud il fait bon et je connais un
bon tout simplement c'est les habits en
caoutchouc sas et elles sont fermes
pittoresque mais est-ce que vos deux
veaux de paris gauche et puis le pari de
belleville sont si différents d'un viol
probablement pas mais moi j'ai je suis
né sur la rive gauche
j'étais à l'école sera à nouveau j'ai
passé mon certificat de ce maillot je me
suis mariée soit homogène et je ne suis
pas passée à rive droite avant 18 ans on
est aux comptes mails leurres après par
contre nager un peu explorées
arrivera t j'ai notamment usé pas mal de
paires de chaussures au bol et au delà
est ce que vous le pensez ceci le
narrateur diamant persuadé que les deux
faits majeurs du xxème siècle la
déconfiture du catholicisme et la
prolifération des partouzes on va vous
voyez oui dans homo c'est évident avec
la déconfiture de 14 noms mais est ce
qu'on pensait que ces deux choses les
plus importantes du 20e siècle
oui enfin ça c'est des positions fermes
oui on est obligé entre danse et la
prolifération du par tous ses secrets
non plus quand j'étais jeune quand on
veut parler de gens qui faisaient déjà
tous été chouchouté c'était honteux on
est regardé avec une espèce de crainte
maintenant vous prenez un verre à saint
germain des prés il ya des règles
légales dans un bistrot qu'ils auront
une partouze il manque un gaz
je voulais venir ça a évolué
considérablement le champ bien chômage
ça alors ça change du xxème siècle vous
voyez où gay